[Music]
we are live
with nikki ortega hi nikki
hi
thanks so much for coming on the show
thank you atlas for having me
so excited for this
so stoked
i love your presence online it's become
it's well articulated like you do a good
job at sharing with people what this is
all about
and it's fun
yeah i just try my best to express it i
never you know i'm like does this make
sense i'm just gonna post that yeah
and i'm like
okay hopefully someone's gets it
and yeah
yeah and uh
as i've been sort of like looking
through what you share i've been finding
that like you have a unique flavor you
know you have everyone that sort of like
wakes up has their own unique taste or
flavor on on what it is and so like
that's a great first place to just kick
it off so let's talk about like yeah
your flavor your taste maybe take us to
like how
um
what how how you got sparked to seek
truth and then what you found
hm well that's so general and broad but
i'll try my best um
flavor
it all started with suffering i guess a
lot of people that getting the awakening
pad is true depression or suffering or
just trying to find a way or meaning out
of the same mental loops and
i was in a really dark place and
just a lot of
addiction
i was addicted to any high it was like
anything that made me feel good and take
me out of that space of turmoil or
trauma or not looking at myself it's
like that's it and eventually i got
tired of running away and
hit a bottom and
went to aea i was never an alcoholic but
i needed something to like feel holding
space feel unconditional love feel
connection to god and at that moment
that's what that was closest to me
and really helped me i did that for
three years but there was still a lot
more to work with and just a constant
part of surrendering and learning about
myself and
sharing my journey with others
that's the summary there's a lot more
identity nice yeah
okay so
you had
pretty intense like suffering patterns
and you were like seeking like highs
like but trying to like alleviate the
suffering and also like seek pleasure
yes completely it was just like so
painful that anything can be food it
could be sex it could be love could be
cuddling could be anything like
yeah
nice yeah
well okay
and
and this is the circle but then then
there's the moment of okay you like you
gain a level of like metacognition
so you gain awareness of that pattern
right and so you like unfreeze some of
your will and you're like [ __ ] this
pattern i don't want to keep suffering
like this i don't want to keep seeking
all these external things so yeah when
so when that um
when that how did that awareness like
unfreeze for you how did you gain more
sovereignty
to go to aaa and to do this yeah process
let me tap into that yeah it was a
really toxic relationship with my
boyfriend at the time and we got into a
really crazy fight and i was just like
knocking the door like crazy like open
the door just like in the movies you
know and the crazy side girls just like
let me in it was just like a mirror of
you need to find your own connection to
self and then when i was there he was
about to call the cops and i got like a
epiphany like okay security is coming
the cops are going to come in you want
to have that memory in your
consciousness that just like got dragged
from this place or you want to just
wake the [ __ ] up and then i was like
this is not okay like why am i trying to
feel a void with this
and then i remember just going into
it's like i can't even see it it was
like a bench in the lobby of his
apartment i was just like crying like my
heart was like bleeding out i was like
felt no connection at home
super dysfunctional family
no real friends no real connections that
was like my only source of something to
hold on into
and then i was like
i need help
and instantly i thought of a friend that
had gone to aaa and i was like maybe
this can help me it's not it's not
alcohol but it's something that is going
to allow me to release this addiction
for
quote unquote love
yeah
okay cool so there was both a trigger
for more self-sourcedness
and then there was also the the memory
of like somebody else having gone
through aaa a friend
and and seen and you saw a change in
them and so then there's like all these
different in a sense there's these uh
programs or these there's places
um these offerings that exist that sort
of serve people as they seek
and then uh okay cool so yeah so then
did you find what did you find there
that then like further sparked more
excitement around truth
acceptance like every time i spoke or
said something everybody was just like
oh we love you and that's something i
never got at my house because everybody
had their own distortions their own
traumas and every time i speak was like
shut the [ __ ] up or you're a piece of
[ __ ] or you know a lot of
just unconsciousness so when i was there
it's like anything i said it was like oh
it's just that it's left and i'm like
okay this is safe so it was like the
first sense of like safety and feeling
whole just like being myself
yeah
nice acceptance safety love amelia
and like then did you also feel like
some of the external seeking also kind
of you know died down a little bit like
you didn't need to go and try and
alleviate suffering and try and go and
seek a high but that you were becoming
more whole just as you were
oh yes
i wish it was instance like some
awakenings people are just like that's
it no it's been quite a journey i think
that was like nine years ago but
yeah it was like the first taste of like
safety and there were a lot of
jump in it's like having one feet in
hell and one in heaven like i was just
juggling and of course the
unconsciousness wasn't fully integrated
so i had to it's like having two people
inside of you now i feel like i have a
thousand but they're all like aligned so
i was juggling between the part of me
that wanted to heal and find that safety
and the shadow self that still wanted to
feel those patterns for a while then it
it's a process yeah
and then so that was nine years ago
right
i believe so yeah i was like
yeah
you were 18.
yeah okay
i i don't remember near 19 yet
yeah
okay and then
so how about like how about after that
like some people
go and they start you know going to
retreats or they start uh
reading or they
take entheogens or they learn about what
meditation is and how it can enhance
their life yeah so what did you end up
like finding over the last years that
has
shared what the nature is with you
what comes up
i found my main spiritual teacher i love
david hawkins
nice yeah i recently so much with his
pat because he was also part of aa and
he's been through hell in heaven a
million well he was he's he's gone now
but he's spirited he's still here
so in in the group one of the guys was
reading one of his books letting go and
i felt so cold to it and then i felt the
mob of consciousness i found
enlightenment i found but then i became
an addict of enlightenment so i was like
oh i found something that's gonna cure
me from this so i'm gonna become my
god devotee
which is better than something else but
yeah that was also a program that now
it's more like subtle it's like ah i see
that
nice so cool so
yeah so david hawkins influenced and
then
um you also saw through the program of
sort of waking up and then just only
talking about the pattern of waking up
to everybody and just having a halo
around your head and that type of thing
so you saw through that
yeah
it's really really harsh it was i think
a whole year of hippiness but people
keeping us i'm like yeah it's all love
and light and like the butterflies and
the rainbows but i wasn't it's like i
never know when it's gonna end every
time i'm like assume you're free but
keep the humbleness to see what comes up
because
that was a year that i was completely in
ecstasy
and as an addict i'm like maybe i'm just
invited now you know i was just like
that's it i never felt any pain
whatsoever so
i think that i wasn't ready at that
moment to integrate even more
unconscious things it's just like so
deep it's like consciousness i see it as
like a game of operando so you know that
surgery game of like the little guy that
has
in one's consciousness and everything i
think i'm done i'm like nope second part
and then i have to take more stuff but
it always gets more
more whole more fluid less leakages of
energy more centered
yeah
yeah that's a cool that's a cool way to
to visualize it we've also
been talking about it like uh
like an unlike the onion layers that get
constructed and then the deconstruction
of the onion layers but in your analogy
that's like in the
game of operation the onion layers are
like all those little pieces that you
pluck out um
all what is not you
exactly
yeah which i believe is so important
because
part of why i didn't want to look at the
beet stuff it's because i still
identified with it i'm like oh that's me
i don't want to talk about that that's
shameful but then i'm like oh that's not
me and
process continues
yeah yeah
so
would you say that
let's well let's talk about uh two two
things because i want to talk about both
um
how your serving people now um see
through their own what is not them and
see through their own game of uh
deconstructing and operation and
acceptance and
etc
but then i also want to talk to you
about
um
what you have found to be like the
nature and how you communicate the
nature
also
so
um
let's start
let's start with that let's start with
the second one and then we'll talk about
the patterns that sort of uh
like that deconstruct to gain insight so
yeah what would you say like if somebody
was to like ask you like how do you
describe what the nature of reality is
like what do you say
the absolute reality
or how it pops up into existence
i see it as simultaneous
discovery of
god's essence and i said simultaneous
because i've been in hell so many times
i've been in heaven and now i feel like
finally i'm integrating on earth so it's
like
reality is so vast but in this earth
plane it's we can travel and
journey through all these riyams and all
these
parts of consciousness just to get to
know more about ourselves it's just a
discovery of god true god
so it's just fun it's like a playground
but the absolute reality of everything
is just empty i see it as just
nothingness and it's like we're all
pixels
creating and expanding and expressing
but then when i reach that point of
emptiness i'm like okay that's boring
let's fill it with love so then i'm like
it's divine love expressing itself
through stories and now i see every
story like an amusement like even the
story i told you about when i was 18 i'm
like that's entertainment like people go
to movies and pay to see that [ __ ] you
know i'm like
it's fun
so it's about going through those things
and then realizing when you're out of it
and you can heal the quote-unquote pain
or suffering that it was just
entertainment you're amusing yourself
through yourself
yeah yeah
so divine love that's that would be my
final answer
yeah
nice
hmm
cool
okay cool so i like how yeah divine love
um
as a final answer and then you also have
a
um you said god's essence which i like
as well
um
so do you normally
do you normally reference that as
uh something that's like a field or
something that has more of like an
oceanic like texture to it
um something that has like a like a
homogeneous like unity uh nature to it
[Music]
like in the absolute i see it as as
oneness but
in the relative plane i see it as a
field because we everybody as you said
in the beginning where everybody carries
a unique flavor and frequency of god so
even when i'm talking to you like i
don't see you like in your body or like
i see you as the whole field that is
around you and that's animating the
character into whatever it wants to say
and express with the intentions and
that's the importance of
where are we coming from and integrity
it's like okay we're animating the
character let's just have fun and use
this toy for good
nice sweet sweet
so
so you
you see
the simultaneity of the
underlying essence of unity but also in
the
way that it's apparently expressing
itself as
diversity and multiplicity and play and
dance
with itself
i think i didn't understand the first
thing diversity would dance
uh yeah dance like dance like it's like
yeah
yeah yeah yeah
but but so yeah you see so you do see
like a simultaneity of a unity and
diversity at the same time
now i do yeah because going back to
my state of full ecstasy and bliss
i couldn't see like the diversity i was
like all this one and that's it but now
i find beauty in the shadows and in the
quote-unquote darkness and all the
expressions of the creator and see the
relevance of it and how that's the
mirror to wake the part of ourselves
that are unconscious or repaint karmas
as i do believe in karma sense
nice nice
so
and so when you when you
uh
when you're sharing about divine
love um
[Music]
what are you typically let's let's let's
get into the patterns now what are
typically the the blockages that you see
that people have
uh and then
what ways uh do you typically see people
liberating themselves of the blockages
beautiful
emotional attachment and all i say is
from the patterns i had
to not finding my own divinity and that
unconditional love that's always here
it's just seeking for a payoff
seeking for gain coming from
self-seeking motives
so every time we want something from
someone or we want to get or yeah take
then that's an attachment it's like
trying to find love in all the wrong
places as cliche as it sounds
it's just like all that search for god
how i see it even when you want success
even relationship or money or
business success it's like searching god
in those things which are beautiful but
it's empty so any attachment that
promise you a better future of tomorrow
or guilt from the past because i didn't
do that right like oh i'm i'm unworthy
etc
that's the blockage from the divinity
that always is and that doesn't mean
that we can have beautiful desires and
creation but all of that coming from
that space of i'm so joyful right now
and i know i'm complete let's create
from that happiness and that joy you
serious and that's on but
yeah
so
it's it's almost like a getting you see
a like a getting lost in
uh thought or emotion or separation
that type of
pattern
or projecting better
results
in the next now moment which never comes
because it's just forever
yeah
yeah
interesting
and then
so then
let's say that there is a
like a blockage of
um somebody that's like
learning how to become aware of their
thinking patterns are you typically
referring them to something specific how
do you walk them through
like gaining more
uh meditative insight
just asking what's the most stressful
thought at the moment
um and having them go directly there so
okay so let's say
uh
give an example of what they say and
then how you continue
they could be like
so many examples i'm like what can be
something really good
like it had this client that
one of the examples of business success
like had
everything that quote unquote on paper
was
good enough to feel successful and happy
and then it's like well i achieve
success in my business in my marriage
and i have beautiful kids i have this
wonderful house i can retire right now
but
i am depressed i feel like [ __ ] i'm like
why so
it's like
i don't feel
worthy of any of this
seems like
why not and then you go into that and
then they open up a different layer it's
like well i achieved this true lying i
manipulated this person or okay so why
do you do that and then they tell well
when i was 10 my dad did this to me and
then what happened then what was your
thought and then we go to the root of
like what was the main
situation that created that
pattern of having to act from fear and
manipulate or
do something to get something for
completeness when you should become good
because you exist
does that make sense
100
100
okay
so you would say that like one of the
ways that you do it is you
help
reflect
to
your other self
you help reflect to them that
there's some pattern at the root of
their experience at the root of their
expression that has a flavor of a lack
belief of some sort
and then that's causing them to feel
this downstream unworthiness or seeking
validation or whatnot
and then
you
and in so in that process then when they
reflect on themselves
and that and that whatever is at the
root of the way that they express
then
then they go through a process of loving
and accepting
that
and liberating
i love how you see it so systematically
i see it's so like intuitive like a
butterfly like i never know what's gonna
happen in the session so i'm just trying
to express it yeah
yeah usually they just hit like a sweet
spot and they call it like the gem or
like they find the treasure underwater
which is like their biggest source of
trauma which is also their greatest gift
and then
they just like start crying or they open
up or they
feel like i relieve sometimes
i just say something funny and they
start laughing and see like the
unconsciousness behind it so
it just really flows it's never one way
for everyone i just come with the
intention and something beautiful
happens sometimes it's not even
questions
it's just they ask me questions about
myself and then through my stories they
open up and see something
that can happen too so
yes
yeah and then and then do they typically
stay
with
you in terms of
like there's a there's a good amount of
in a sense uh work that is then done
from
uh noticing
one of your deep traumas and then
feeling like the liberation of that and
purifying the way you express yourself
but then also recognizing like the field
recognizing divine love itself
recognizing infinity recognizing
nothingness emptiness
that there's there's a big there's how
so now how have how have clients have
you do you usually work with them
through that entire process or is it
sometimes people just you know drop off
after that little bit of liberation and
release um or do you also take people
all the way with as they seek
i have it actually just happened twice
and it's it was just so wonderful
because it was not only working it
actually started with the enlightenment
state of feeling the oneness and the
divinity which is a reflection of me
because first i allowed
all that beautifulness and then i'm like
how do i play this in the relative
realms and then working through
their relative ones and how to express
that better and how to be more in
alignment than in truth so
yeah but sometimes it's just one session
and i never see them again but i do love
more when it's
consistent because you get to see such a
beautiful transformation and then it's
just like tears of joy and it's like oh
like
i changed my whole relative life but
that wasn't it like
i just feel peace
yes
yeah right okay so
um so i see how like the it's easier for
people to
understand like the emptiness of
the
material materiality like that that's
that that's
i feel like that's one of the easier
ones for people to click
um
but then for example how do you get
people how do you reflect to people that
their sense of self is not located like
behind their eyes
how do you get them to understand the
field how do you get them to get yeah
do you understand it
yeah how do you get them or how do you
get them to realize it and then to be it
usually i do attract people that
understand that
you do you
you wait so so so you attract people
that are already
aware of
no self
exactly
really yes that's how it works and
usually it's more working into
the physical plane which is what i have
had to do in the past years so
it's always me like my client is myself
like talking about here so i'm just
attracting a reflection of my past self
or your future self
so it's like playing with that and as
they heal i heal too because they open
up and then i see something else and i
open up it's always i learn teach so
i don't really try to explain them it
kind of like
they know that and they just want to
know how to
manage that in the physical
yeah
okay i think this is a really important
beautiful point
so
when you yeah when you're speaking from
the absolute perspective and i think
this is really important
um you know nikki just shared that
whenever she likes whenever somebody
like approaches her like seeking
that she sees it as
past or future self
so she sees it as
like serving herself basically
so then there's
nothing to like get out of it there's
the teach learning learn teach aspect to
it of course but in terms of there's
nothing like to extract out of it
because you're already whole so you're
not trying to like prove yourself and
all this type of stuff
um
i love that that uh that view of it but
so how does how do you how do you
how do clients gravitate towards you
that have already experienced no self or
have already recognized no self like
that's already uh
that's already pretty like end of path
what the [ __ ]
i think it's so funny i never thought
about it i think it's because i spent
like two years writing about the
absolute that of course that's what i'm
going to attract now i'm like i want to
learn how to write about my human aspect
so that's what i'm working on now but
it's
yeah that makes sense we attract what we
are so
elected group though like i wish that's
why i want to work on the human because
i wish to reach more people if they feel
called to it and relate to that
humanness
okay so
to an extent
you would
maybe describe it as
you
waking up
seeing no self clearly
and then being that for two years
writing about it the absolute
then
sharing
that with
people
to wear with yourself
then
you see that like you are gravitating
people that want to basically understand
that at a deeper level that have already
maybe tasted it um that type of thing
but then also that are
wanting to like you become interested in
like anchoring in a sense these like
heavenly realizations in the physical so
in materiality like helping the shift
the planetary awakening
yes i love how you word it so beautiful
that's why i it's a focus on integration
because when i got all those
realizations i wasn't aware that
now i had to go even deeper in my
unconscious and bring those parts of
myself into that realism because it was
like a split really really high
realization and then have to take my
human with me and then the ego is like
no no i don't want to like don't make me
do that
so
that's
so excites me so much just to think
about it like bringing that wholeness so
every time i talk to someone i'm like i
see your wholeness but relatively
there could be some work to do as well
yes
yeah
yeah that's the simultaneity of
both yeah being completely whole already
perfect but yet also there being some
little bit of mud uh that can be shined
off the diamond uh in a sense
yeah that can be liberated yeah the
illusion further liberated
um
interesting so
so okay so take take us through then
like an example of what it's like for so
so you say sometimes it's like anchoring
a client's no self-realization
into like just basic everyday life and
interactions like the human
and
so sometimes it's that and then
sometimes it's it's
somebody that has no idea what no self
is and they're still just learning about
their own traumas yeah
so you so you span that whole spectrum
yeah that's beautiful that's a good way
to say it
like
um
yeah because somebody that's in the full
months of depression like i know how to
take them back to okay i feel great
right now
and then somebody that's in the absolute
nothingness like okay that's cool but
when they ask me like so what now do i
keep meditating do i keep like chanting
do i keep i'm like just watch tv and
have fun and
go talk to your friends like that's a
broad example but it's that's why i love
the cliche of nirvana samsara it's like
being back to the human and enjoy it
from that space of that new realization
but
shop would carry water you know whatever
it is
yeah
yeah i love yeah the zen 10 bowls is so
good too after this yeah after the
journey is just you're back in the
market drinking wine 100
yeah
yeah
so true i relate to that i'm like i even
stopped drinking for a while became
vegan now it's like i don't care i can't
wake up and have a shot of whiskey
myself you know i don't give a [ __ ]
i know it's so good
yeah
okay cool
um
okay so then do you do you also feel
like you inspire um
yourself uh yourselves your other selves
do you feel like you inspire them
um to then like become more like
shepherds or like have more service to
others energy because it's it's almost
like
you can
many times like you were describing in
the realization awakening process that
there can be a
uh a loss of interest in
anchoring any thing into like the world
into the collective but really it's all
of you that just wants to wake up so you
may as well do that
do you
yeah yeah yeah it just remind me of
myself in my balcony for like two months
just like bliss the [ __ ] out i'm like i
have no interest in coming back to the
world i'm like you're in the world girl
come on so i think it's just a natural
thing the more awareness we get we want
to use this to help others but
i had to balance that too because where
is that coming from it's like i want to
be of service or it's like just by being
they're being observed
yeah
sometimes we don't have to do anything
and just by our vibration alone we're
helping or even by [ __ ] up we're
hoping because that's another flavor of
the creators so
it's beautiful
i love that so let's let's talk about
that distinction a little bit more
because i feel like it's relevant um
so
uh yeah if you feel like uh you have a
you have an urge for being in service
and that you want to show up and like be
in service that like nikki said it's
about checking where you're coming from
so that you can distinguish between when
you're coming from wanting to be seen or
being worthy or validated or whatever
versus when literally your state of
being itself
can just vibrationally emit to somebody
like receptivity or availability and
then people will just come to you and
then they themselves will maybe like ask
a question or
they'll uh provide an inquiry of some
sort or maybe it's just geeking out and
just like smiling and laughing and
playing and then that yeah yeah that's
it that's so wonderful i
i love that line right away from the
anurag and venting where are you coming
from but guess that's where i wanna
credit
oh good whoa it's just so subtle it's
like one single mantra and it changes
the overall intention it's like putting
a filter in your computer hardware like
your consciousness and then everything
you say it's like you cannot [ __ ]
yourself i'm like
that's great
yes yeah
where are you
five words yeah where are you coming
from yeah it's so good
it's so good
because because you can't go any further
back that source where you're coming
from like
like your stylus pen basically like your
will the paintbrush you can't go any
further back
than that yeah
and then
you go
what were you to say
like let's play
um
and that helps a lot even when being of
service because then
it's easy for me to know like oh now
or also excitement it's like i want to
do this video with you this interview
because it's exciting so then it's
coming from that space of soulfulness
and
authentic service but if it's like i'm
bored i don't know how to do that let's
just make a video too
to try to help people because i'm
unhappy then it's like where is the
service so it's just that would be
validation or proving one style but
no
so that's the balance of shepherding
that i feel it's so important for
for me and the collective as well to
glance and put into practice
yeah
[Music]
just getting a lot of love in the chat
oh i didn't know we were live
hi
i'm like we connected this i'm like okay
now
sending you massive love back so good
yeah
so good
so good
um
cool so i like that you care so much
about that mantra and that you feel like
where are you coming from can be like a
big access point for people to like
purify themselves which is
huge very relatable super relatable
i have another uh
i have another cool
[Music]
topic
so
i feel like this is important actually
it's much more important than i think
than gets
shared
which is
um
that what people seek
with uh like self-realization or god
realization
is equivalent to
anata or no self which then is capital s
self
do you feel
like
that like they're different flavors of
the same coin
like two sides of the same coin no self
and capital s self or how do you see
that
i see no self as the emptiness like the
void
getting to that state or non-state it's
like the realms of paradox i love that
topic getting to the non-state of
there is nothingness it's just emptiness
it's just like a black canvas to play
with and then the south with capital s i
see it as what i mentioned before the
divine love the colors the glitter the
rainbows the butterflies or
art the crying the sorrow all the
spectrum of the human emotions so all of
that it's like the higher self
expressing itself through the linear
expression of your small self as well
but it's simultaneous but there's also
the emptiness but
i do believe in my experience that if i
stop in the emptiness then
why am i here like i came back to play
and express the highest self through my
highest frequency excitement
so
yeah it's two sides of the same coin
expressed into one although some people
and i think
buddha teaching sometimes it's just into
the emptiness and the void and dances
that's it no need to talk
yeah
whatever they appreciate in the journey
i guess
yeah interesting so you see uh no self
you see emptiness as more of the blank
canvas
and then you see more of the self god
divine love you see that as the
creative
capacity
everything from ignorance to knowledge
everything and that's i'm gonna share
this like like the human will completely
align with divine will i see that as the
self and when we have that complete
alignment then everything we do
it's from self it's god expressing
itself from the highest frequency of
love
in the void of emptiness
that is like everything that surrounds
us
but we need both because if not there
would be no world why would we be here
anyways yes
yeah
[Music]
you know it's so nice like just feeling
it and like just
being it and seeing it so clearly and
then just
like relaxing
um because like you found yourself and
you found yourself so clearly um
and you found yourself everywhere and
you found yourself nowhere um
and
and like and it's so nice having these
very simple analogies like the blank
canvas and the infinite creation it's
just it's so it becomes so simple or
like the screen
like you we have all these like devices
now and it's just this black it's this
blank screen and then
[Music]
perfect
yeah
how many different ways can it modulate
or how many you know how many different
ways can the m the blank
notes no notes musical notes turn into
songs i mean there's so many different
ways to how many different ways to
vibrate your vocal chords into languages
so you can see all the different ways
that the creator can express itself as
uh anything from ignorance of its nature
to knowledge impurity um of its nature
anything from somebody that it doesn't
have their basic needs being met that's
starving and struggling all the way to
the most like wealthy most abundant um
spaceship flyer
space supplier yeah
i love that
that's it just holographic particles
start that is expressing themselves
but the beauty of finding that
self or that absolute realization like a
taste of it at least is it frees us to
express our human nature with so much
more
freedom and not caring about whatever
happens or like not judging ourselves
and just navigating every scene with ah
it's fine i'm just playing free pens
here
without difficulty but yeah it's you're
playing whatever role it's the most
relevant for the moment
yes
yeah i think your
yeah your bio on instagram says like
movie character
because i had so many identity shifts
every time i had like a mini ego dead
and then like integrated something new
that i got tired every day i woke up and
i'm like healer uh spiritual teacher
shifter dude i'm like disney symbols to
try to convey a message
to help someone if they're in need but
it's just like we're all the same so
it's just like a character whatever role
we want to play align with our
intentions and our excitement that's
what we came here to do so
yeah no labels
i feel like it's so helpful
like recognizing like the simple even
like you're even like the pupil itself
like the eye
um and like yeah the way that like the
pupil and the iris
is
yeah because it's
like it is like the pupil is like the
blank canvas and the iris is like this
infinite creativity
[Music]
playing with itself but i found one of
the one of the keys in a sense
is
to
to not
get like hooked on anything that you
like land on as ground because
um
because there's so much more to still
gain insight into
yourself can yeah because like i've
noticed that people will gain insight
find a ground and then they'll like
stand on that and be horizontal and
they'll like keep looking horizontally
yeah i'm fully guilty of that like
taking their relaxation and then being
like oh this is it and then everything
is like that that's it so i'm just like
i'm stagnant again and then i don't give
room for growth or like shifting so i'm
like everything we say right now
it's in this moment maybe tomorrow i'll
change my mind so
because there's no mind so
just allowing the flow that comes
through
yeah
yeah
i love that and it reminds me of the
freshness
and then yeah bentino talks about that
quite a lot this like fast refresh rate
where you don't get fixated on anything
ever
and it's just like perpetual freedom
like always not this not batting your
whole existence
and
it's just so liberating because it's
like whatever we're showing up as right
now
yeah we're gonna deepen our insight and
deepen our purification tomorrow and
it's going to show up and express itself
freshly and differently
[Music]
but the underlying principle
like that like the major shift
in awakening
um would you say for you it's kind of
like seeing and for you and for like the
way you share it and serve other people
that it's
seeing
yourself
in all
yeah but
comes about with discernment as well
um
i think that's the balance of the wisdom
that i've been purifying purifying yeah
uh this whole year
it's just
i can see myself and everyone else
myself but
taking care of my own needs as well too
not because you are myself then i'm
going to give myself everything right
now to you and i was
really unbalanced and loved before so
finding that balance of discernment
nice yeah
cool so so we can we can agree that like
the major shift when we talk about
things like awakening is like sort of
decentralizing your like contraction
from being just like a person
to being the all to like remembering
yourself as the all right then to not
and this is where with like the law of
one where we talk about things like the
fourth density balancing love balancing
with fifth density wisdom into a unified
sixth density of love light
and
lovelade awareness
and
i like that point because it's really
common including for myself
to continue
the subtle process of recognizing like
am i detecting is this detecting benefit
and is it detecting benefit
with
the
for like the highest possibility right
now
you know or is the highest possibility
actually the like expressing love to my
other self here
and taking a step back
and going into whatever the other
uh
like relaxed state or creative state or
whatever
and then having it serve at a greater
level
yeah kind of making that intuitive more
and more with in my experience like with
every situation that presents itself it
just became more clear and easier like
oh no need to say anything here or or if
i do it then i see it more rapidly like
oh that was unbalanced okay
navigating that
okay and then you you would say that
then
as you sort of begin
like seeing yourself as the all you
would say that another big way of
of
playing the game
is to
recognize where you're coming from or
like pay attention like very like
vigilance basically with where you're
coming from as you awaken like you would
say that that's like a a major pairing
i love how also david hawkings express
it when he's like there's comes a point
in your awareness and in your spiritual
journey that
it's like in every little subtlety you
feel like dog peed in the bed like if
you weren't in the bed and you wake up
and you're like oh that it's impossible
not to see it it's like it smells it's
it's clear so it's just like
can't get away with it like the program
wants to go up and it's like oh okay no
it's just like i see it like screen and
then it just passes by and i'm like oh
you again nice and then i keep moving it
so it cancels itself out
whoa
nice way to describe it yeah yeah i love
it we've also been talking about it like
thought advertisements basically so it's
like you're it's like the yeah the
advertisement pops up it's like would
you like to entertain in more
unworthiness or separation and it's like
no
[Laughter]
i love it it reminds me of that
show i think it's an msn upgrade i think
it's the name
and it's just like different ads it's
like you want this right now it's like
that it's just like a little animal i
call the ego the animal itself like
remind yourself you want this the one
that's like no i don't want that thank
you but no
yeah
cool so yeah so you're you're hinting at
like what is
we are hinting at in in this sort of
like later
later stage
of
like really noticing with vigilance that
you create your own thought
advertisements that are purposely there
for you to decline or accept and forget
for a period of time to then be like
[ __ ] why did i do that and then wait and
then wake up more
yeah
it's so exciting to me i'm like yes i
just feel like i'm in the field now like
let's play it's just
like the surgery like operation game as
i said
it's just
you get to see it and it's wonderful
when the same situation doesn't cut you
anymore like i thought that had so much
momentum due to previous karma it's like
oh now you have built so much background
awareness that it just falls off and
before it just got stuck and got
expressed and you're like why did i
accept that it's just a program but
every time more and more just
flushes itself out
yeah it's like taking a [ __ ]
totally
it's really good
push that [ __ ] out yeah
yeah
oh that's so good
so good
that [ __ ] that's
that's made of divine love that i
purposely covered myself with
exactly yeah it's like it's fine i can
put it on and wear it but at some point
it's going to smell so i'm like
okay okay let's take a shower
[Laughter]
fine too i'm like if i have it on
doesn't mean i'm not worthy i'm also
worthy so
yeah
yeah and uh anurag has been uh leading
the last couple of sessions for no limit
society and it's been really nice
because he really simplifies things down
a lot
um
like really simple just like one word
like honor like when you come from honor
you're always you know purely serving
the creation um without self-interest
from an empty place
um
and it's really interesting because he
uses these analogies like soccer and
he'll just be like
like the moment that the thought
advertisement comes up in the soccer
game while you're [ __ ] on a team
and then you get concerned about oh the
past or the future or how i look to the
audience or whatever it is that
immediately like you lose flow you're
kicked off of the [ __ ] team you know
that type of of of vibe so
um
like it's it's really simple also in
like
classic like billions of people play
sports or they play games or they um
they do activities in flow states
and
everybody knows the feeling of
like the moment that you're
that you're like you're cooking you're
cooking a dish
in order
for the people you're cooking it for to
tell you how much they love it
versus
yeah versus actually like picking it
with love just to serve it to yourselves
their other selves so that yeah yeah
like you can tell like that's the style
of distinction
that's more about let's do something for
the better tomorrow
let's do something for finally feeling
worthy successful complete when i get
this so then it's like the continuous
chase for happiness that never ends in
the loop of like let's search within
again cliche but it's
people want it like more complex like
they said that but it's like it's just
here
behind the mud sometimes the mud has a
lot of momentum
that's why we do the work
interesting so you also said i like how
you called it for a better tomorrow
it sounds like a song
[Laughter]
oh my gosh
it never comes then i'm always like like
a rabbit like chasing it like the card
and then the card is dangling and i'm
like
wait the card it's it's oh it's here oh
cool
i'll eat it myself
yeah
wow so the illusion could be summarized
as a rabbit chasing a carrot on an
endless treadmill
yes
wow beautiful or like a little cartoon
that is like on top of you and it's in
front and you're just like never gonna
chase it you're just like
chasing your own illusion i'm like wait
i have the power to take that thing out
and just move the carrot and eat it oh i
had the power all this time it was just
covered with the mud
yeah
i love that you are the carrot
yes
and there's nowhere
there's no there's no there's nowhere
that you could
go on to a treadmill to get to
because you're already the carrot
yeah
and you're also placing the treadmill
there because you wanted some trill
and drama and like let's create a hero's
journey that's why you're the movie
character
nice yeah so like we
we designed our own yeah our own movie
our own
our own odyssey our own like hero's
journey uh and so yeah we wanted a
little bit of drama to like really like
how i like i wrote a couple of uh
days ago or a week ago something like
how badly can i forget and remember
like how badly
can i
get drowned in illusion and [ __ ] wake
myself up yeah
yeah but fun
oh beautiful scenes
oh
so sweet
yeah
nice nikki nice love your vibe
bye bye i'm so grateful to be here thank
you for
inviting me
it's so nice yeah it really is and your
heart's so warm
you radiate really beautifully
i try
instantly i had the butt but i am see
how it cancels itself out i'm like you
cry but you are i'm like stop it
that stuff is gone paradox
so this is a key
milestone or like a key
um when you get to sort of the
transcension of all paradoxes
um the transcension of all like
entangled dualities
yeah
it's so rich because i i've we mentioned
several on the
in our conversation
the whole well
oneness but also appearing like
this diverse form this formlessness
appearing as their reforms emptiness
appearing like fullness
um or
um
or like illusion and
reality or you know this type of that
these types of dualities where
like you recognize that you're the
source of it
simultaneously and it's just like it's
so transcending
it is
it's yeah it's it's a roller coaster
right
like
and then the same place and it's just
like it becomes a circle
yeah
yeah
it's like all the aspects of self are
like in the how you call that the wheel
like of an amusement park you know that
oh the ferris wheel that one and i see
like all the aspects in the ferris wheel
and they all connect that wholeness in
the middle and that's like the complete
simultaneity and then they're like
okay okay so what's on the carts like
what's in all the little carts on the
outside like all the different emotions
or like expressions
the aspects once they are all aligned
like because before i had so much split
it's like my inner child wanted
something but my teacher asked like
wanted this so i was dragging my inner
child with me or like i have a granny
self that's everybody has like an inner
wife's grandmother or grandfather
or like a comedian right so all the
aspects of the self which i see that
eventually it's the whole world is
inside of us so every archetype just
into wholeness and when we come from
that place of the middle
then that's it because we are in that
simultaneity of whatever aspect needs to
show up just shows up
and we don't get any identity it's just
like all and nothing
yeah
yeah sweet i love that so
the
the
carts around the outside can be
potentially the spectrum of illusion to
reality or
uh identity as like separation or
identity as the creator
no knowledge
okay and then all the different
expressions that all have the same
origin or source or wholeness
yeah
and i see the pad like at some point is
having like the higher self in the
classroom telling all the aspects like
this is what we're gonna do today in the
board with like a little marker and
there comes a point where they're all
aligned that there's no need for a class
it's just like they all know what's the
duty because they're all one
so oh
[ __ ] nice so
interesting so like okay when you wake
up in the morning
um
one of the ways that you could look at
like your day
um which which of course practicing
future presence which we talk about
which is like seeing a really successful
day and yeah yeah and seeing like divine
love in the whole day um but you can
also take it from this like from this
perspective of ah today we're gonna be
learning you know xyz like yeah
and then and then it becomes like you're
saying it becomes more and more like
effortlessly flowful and intuitive
and like clear and you don't necessarily
have to like remind yourself all the
time that that's what's happening
exactly that's it and then i got a
flashback of a point on the journey like
maybe like little nikki just like run up
the classroom i'm like what the [ __ ]
girl i come here we're having a class
and she's like no
but now she has a candy lollipop she's
like
she's there like okay i behave now
oh she was a drag i love her
and i express it that way so it can have
some like relevance but
i rather say i
like she
okay so
how do you how do you feel about
um
as as we wake up as the collective wakes
up it's really clear that the
architectures
they
like mirror our consciousness
so
uh like the planet's consciousness is
very clearly
drowned in samsara or ignorance right
now of separation and all this type of
stuff
and so that's why you see these archaic
institutions and governments and
economic policies and
uh polarizing media
hatred violence blah blah blah war
still nukes all this type of stuff but
then we also clearly see like as people
wake up they're like i want to
decentralize everything i want everyone
to have ownership i want i want
i want permaculture regenerative farming
i want i want clean energy for everybody
everybody gets to express themselves
artistically i want that future so
do you see that sort of happening right
now as we awaken as all these new
architectures are being implemented
yeah that's i see that as beautiful like
today i'm here in new york and
they're having this parade like
thanksgiving and you just see the people
in the streets super joyful just smiling
and like hugging and just like doing
dances and shows and i'm like that's it
that's how new earth would look like if
everybody just got over the [ __ ] and
we embody our higher selves it's like
that's it every day would be a parade a
thanksgiving at christmas
and it would be easy but that's what's
happening in this planet at the moment
just separating that into
more enlightenment more alignment yeah
i i think what kanye said i think a
couple of years ago maybe um was that
oh yeah he was running i think in in
2020 for president and i remember him
saying um he wanted to run under the
birthday party
i didn't i didn't fully understand it
until i like really started like waking
up more and more and i was like
every moment should be a [ __ ]
birthday it should be just a celebration
um yeah
how wonderful
yeah imagine that like if everybody
realized they're infinitely worthy to be
who they are they are accepted their
love they forgive everyone which is
forgiving oneself and one's perceptions
we would just like follow our highest
excitement and share love and there is
no even need for the experiment because
everybody would be coming from integrity
so it would be so much easier party
yeah
yeah like total alignment total
discernment
total creativity total celebration
um total basic needs being met it's so
exciting and i mean it's
it is totally what like wakes me up
every single morning is is like
i'm
here for this collective waking up like
without a doubt like without a doubt
this collective
is already the birthday party it's
already heaven and it's becoming more
and more heaven like more and more
purified more awake yeah
wow that's wonderful
and then so you you are both
um
taking one-on-ones so there's links by
the way there's links in the bio um for
everybody to uh nikki's website her
youtube channel her instagram she has
two profiles there um
so
because you're taking both one-on-ones
and you can find that in the bio on her
website but also
you're
producing content
that
shares
in this
mass awakening so you're doing you
you're doing both there's kind of like
two options if people want to like
follow you or like get to um
get more involved with what you share
they can both check it out like
digitally on the content you share
instagram youtube and whatnot where they
can also go one on one with you
yes equally i just
write every day i post something that
comes to me in the moment so
sometimes people it's like hey i've been
following you for a year without a
session and i have shifted so many
things so if the person has the
accountability to do it solo they can't
just with the content if they want more
personalized attention i love that is
so exciting
yeah
and
then
do you feel like
do you feel like the content for you
like this is so cool because it feels
very like gary vee right now i [ __ ]
love it do you do
do you feel like the content that's all
you need to do
are you on tick tock yet
no i'm not oh my god
do you
do you feel like when you share uh and
you're like i'm through to share
do you feel like um
when you know when people like send a
comment on that content they're like oh
like that's such a good way to look at
it or whatever
so you like serve yourself in that way
and then also
when they
like click to like come in for a
one-on-one session have you seen like a
positive feedback loop with like you
know being inspired and also being uh
like fearless and courageous with
sharing and how that feeds back into
like your your happy like your happiness
your peacefulness your network your
prosperity
you mean eye sharing or them sharing
you sharing
oh yes for sure like it's just brings me
joy not even if there's even no result
or not comment or nobody reason it i'm
still like joyful because it
that's how you know it's a calling work
it's like lifts me up
yeah
yeah and by
product of that it helps because it's it
has that vibration though
yes
yes yes
yeah the
the
the byproduct of you sharing is not only
your own process of
like refining how you speak like but
it's all right but it's also the fact
that the content goes out and impacts
your other selves
and then that they become more like
aware of your like of your offerings and
and so there's like there's such a good
feedback loop um that happens from
courage from fearlessness
uh in sharing
but
i would also say and i'm curious do you
feel like the same thing is true
when
you don't share because
you
like gain new
levels of emptiness or like peacefulness
or relaxedness where it's like even
though an insight came through you don't
have to go online and share it right
away but that you can just like relax
into it at the same time yeah wonderful
that goes back to like being of service
because it's intuitive or because i want
to show something
it's more intuitive and the sense that
oh beautiful let this insight integrate
and then see what
beautiful
magic can come through that in whatever
form it's expressed and sometimes it's
just like it's so potent that it needs
to be there it's like oh i don't know
something took my hand and wrote it and
i'm like i don't even know what happened
yeah so that's like a lot of potency and
yeah so it's both it's just like feeling
into it
i love that
do you ever feel like
because let's say like 7.9 billion 99
billion whatever of all your other
selves are all like exactly where they
like need to be
they're all already according to their
own will their own choice their own play
in the dance
they're like exactly where they're
supposed to be and so do you ever also
feel into like
well
if it is me exactly where i'm supposed
to be then why would i share to
to myself
yeah yeah so tell me about that process
for you that's a beautiful product it's
they don't need me
everybody has their own entire stuff
but in my own journey i've been served
so well by mirrors and by teachers and
it helps me so much and it's also fun
it's like why not getting myself show
through this experience yes coaching
session this is like coaching session
but let's play same as going to the
movies but let's play with our own life
so
yeah it's it's like that's why i do it
out of joy not like oh they need my help
nobody needs me like nobody actually
needs you you're just expressing your
own completeness
yeah
and whenever they call me the feedback
they're making a story about me because
whatever they see means it's themselves
so it's like oh she really helped me she
changed my i'm like now you changed your
life through what you see in me so so
good yeah
[Music]
it's like permission slips as catalysts
uh
like
like we
when we sit down with somebody
and it's clear that like one of us is
more unblocked than the other one like
one's more clearly free than the other
one
we we like the less the the more the
more blocked is using the less blocked
as a permission slip for them and a
catalyst for themselves to become uh
less blocked more free
yes
i see it as like my higher self playing
games putting that person there like oh
see yourself through this person because
you are them
and that's what your potential is so
it's just like oh this is me in the
future
that's how i see my teachers just like
oh you're me in the future
so good
so um so when you see like someone
that's more unblocked
and i like how you mentioned this
earlier too that one of the reasons why
you do share also is because you've had
so many other profound
people that you've learned from that
have shared
to help you break free from your own
illusion that
now you just turn around and shepherd
with that same style of compassion
basically um so i like that
um and then so okay so when when you see
someone that's less blocked that's more
free
you see that as a future self
yes
completely and even more if i get
triggered like a part of me in that part
of my journey may have been like oh no
like [ __ ] it like [ __ ] you like the ego
getting like triggered but then it's
like that's an indication that i need to
embody more of that frequency within me
so now it's like a gift it's like oh fun
tell me more like
going back to the classroom and aligning
the aspects
[Laughter]
so that the trigger
itself the thought advertisement comes
up and it's a trigger
um
to see that as
our own
creation of the other self being there
that then creates the trigger thought
advertisement for ourselves to liberate
ourselves from
getting fixated on the trigger and
getting
upset and
uh
like
having
what's what's the word
uh
like
res oh resentment
yeah
right exactly yeah yeah so it's just
like wonderful when we're able to
experience the trigger but be like oh
this is showing me where i need to work
on like
that's beautiful yeah universe triggered
me show me where i'm not free
so it becomes and once we see the
benefit of it then it's exciting and we
want to get triggered
it can be scary because i've been there
too i'm like no no no leave me in my
contracted state i'm safe here
so
that's this wonderful game
playing video games here
okay so you would say that like
when you see reality as a school that
that like a video game school that that
can be one of the most like
clear ways of seeing
yeah i see it like that and we're just
like going through levels and getting
new tools and opening new that's why i
call the sessions the portal because i
see every person as a portal like right
now you're opening just a pathway and
we're in the same space
it's not like you're there and i'm here
we're just sharing frequencies and we're
both getting enhanced by the interaction
so
it's like a person giving you an
opportunity to walk through the portal
that's the person and then you get those
codes and then you put that in your
character and get more upgraded and then
you can go to the trials and
tribulations of life which is just play
but however you want to see it
you know way more free and expanded and
just like frigga you saw that movie
oh yeah such a good movie
yeah like when he kissed the girl got
all the coke and he's like this is how
life is like oh and then he like quit
his job and was able to create more
financial abundance and travel and this
and he was like superhero and i'm like
that's how i see the portal it's like
giving that platform to like
upgrade
yeah
because people have done that for me
just studying that platform and
so grateful
yeah
such a good description
i'm so visual if you haven't noticed
every time you ask me something i'm like
the wheel this that
yeah me too
and it's been fun and i bet it's been
similar for you too where because like
i'm also very visual and i'm very
conceptual and so it's fun to also be
able to be empty of visuals and concepts
yeah have you had like an interesting
experience with like emptying yourself
of visuals and concepts and then also
being able to access them as you need
oh yeah
i mean like two nights ago i was
just telling danny like
i feel empty
like there's nothing like there's no
sensation i feel so much peace
and i enjoyed it but then i got bored
and i'm like okay let's find like a
movie and play with emotions and
sensations
and that's
the beautifulness of nirvana samsara
it's like okay now that i'm empty and i
feel peace i want to play with
characters and archetypes and sensations
and
it's beautiful but i feel like having
that background emptiness it's so
much more
nourishing to play the game of life
because without it then we get caught up
in the characters and the sensations and
we believe that the scene is real but
when you know it's more real then you
can have so much more fun with it
it's so good oh
yeah
oh
man so it's like having the having the
background knowledge
of
source of emptiness of the white canvas
is then what enables you to
like express yourself
um
into the
infinite creation into all of the
possibilities of sensations and
experiences
um
from a place of wholeness but also from
a place that doesn't get lost in the
illusion doesn't get lost in samsara
it's so good
like meaning the world but not of it
also one of my favorite quotes like but
how do i do that i'm like well
we just explained it in the whole
interview
you're the card i'm the card
yeah
[Music]
oh good though it's so s it's so it's so
simple it's that good really like
like
it's such a good statement
i actually changed my bio from movie
career
yeah it's so good
it's so funny because people that people
that like get that you're not talking
about like yourself as a person like
that it's a really important distinction
because otherwise like you can read that
and there's so many interpretations
um
and then like so then you wonder like
well how can i write this so that
almost all different interpretations can
get something uh out of it that doesn't
necessarily trigger them or she thinks
that she's so she's the carrot everybody
should want to [ __ ] be nicki
like she thinks he's a spiritual teacher
who told you you're so advanced you know
all the egos getting like i'm you like
so that's what i'm maybe ironing out at
the moment it's like well
i feel like vibrationally wherever it's
meant to be stuck in my field for
service would happen so i'm like
they would get it so i don't need to
work on it but then suddenly i'm like
this can help much more people so that's
why i tried with terms and symbols like
trauma healer and
emotional coaching i was so against the
word caution before because i saw it as
like like it's not caution we're just
mirroring each other but it's just such
a symbol that the matrix has like
normalized and i'm like let's play with
that
so
yeah
yeah
so almost like you can make a concession
into matrix terminology to help actually
serve people that are seeking that's a
great point yeah i'm trying to do it yes
yeah
i i i actually think that's really
resonant for like if anybody's ever um
like gotten
tastes of like themselves being like
ultimate reality i think i am the carrot
is like a pretty good way
and it all goes back to comedy it's like
have fun trickster you know it's like
i'm the girl it's like the [ __ ] it's so
unreal i'm the character
yeah oh she gets that you know yeah
we're good
another way to maybe say it is yeah
because i'm the carrot so good because
then it's like i'm the reward like i am
i'm the divine like i am absolutely i
mean like that's so good but then um
but then also i really like
something like i am the
like i am the painter in all or whatever
like because then there's like a
you know
like i am the pupil like the one i right
or whatever right that like there's that
kind of um
of way of of like sharing it or
expressing it that then gets people to
like get the mirroring aspect at a
uh
yeah
it's like the carrot it's like shaped
chips into a pen or it's like a pen
carrot and then you can like paint with
it
i'm painting you now
oh what a beautiful creation
and you saw you read like little kitty
things
oh oh
the painter is the carrot
yeah now you get it no like the carrot
it's just the paint yeah yeah yeah it is
an actual brush yes yes
yeah yeah i'm saying like if you know
the painter the one painter is the
carrot like the
one infinite creator is the reward
yes that's it too
yeah yeah like that kind of way of
putting it yeah
but it's so good
like you are already the reward
um
uh
and yet it's also simultaneously that
there's like an apparent like further
liberating oneself of condensed
energy and
um
and behavior patterns that are rooted in
separation because you can't you can't
get away with it you know it's always so
you don't you don't fall for the um
because i i know that it's it's gotten
really common like with neo advaita to
sort of just go directly to say that you
know there's nobody here there's nothing
to do
um
and
and i and i think that um
you you seem like you also see that like
yo like you did apparently have like 25
years of conditioning of separation like
there's probably something to do to like
liberate yourself from
uh that
yeah i'm fully guilty of that too of
being like oh i'm already wanting it so
i don't have to look at my shadow [ __ ]
so it's more i see the carrot or the
background canvas as a way for us not to
feel guilty if the persona or the ego
acts out or says something or
[ __ ] up it's like you're not that so it
instantly liberates us from guilt and
gives us the free space to how can i
work through this how can i own it how
can i choose differently so that's the
beauty of
both worlds or the emptiness and the
love together nice
yeah
and and i i love that and then i've also
found that it's it's really important to
also
um
like the whole there is only one of you
which is also something that bentino's
been adamant about because
we did so it's so easy for us to say
that ah that's the ego and then to
almost like outsource
ourselves to that
um and so to also recognize that this
like
the the conditioned self
is both it's entangled so it's both
not us and us or neither
us nor not us um and so like to
to also be comfortable with that to be
like yeah like in this case in this
example this avatar did apparently have
25 years of conditioning and it still
expresses itself sometimes from there
and that's not a problem because i know
i'm far far beyond that but i am also
purifying this avatars exactly
that removes any
any subtle pain from it or guilt or
i cannot show myself because that would
be vulnerable it's like no it's you're
not that and we're all people who are
doing the same thing so there's that
like collective support into
stepping up into more emptiness
yeah
i have a silly let's play with some
silly questions to to end this is so
good okay yeah
let me just check yeah i think i have
like
just a little bit a couple more minutes
of silly questions yeah
what's your favorite food
pasta i love pasta with like wine just
like a spaghetti with like
vodka sauce i love pink sauce i love
sensuality so i find pasta really
romantic the way you eat it and you
taste it with like the wine and the
sensations and scents
i'd like more italy in the background
and i'm good to go
okay do you have a you have a um
that actually kind of plays me into the
into an even better question to
potentially ask which is what are your
favorite sensations
that's been yes i have a friend that
calls me mrs sensation because we went
to a restaurant and like ordered three
plates and i just tasted it and he's
like why are you doing that such a waste
of money i'm like i just want the
sensation of it
and since then he calls me mr sensation
um
that's just such a subtle question
because i'm like i enjoy bliss but then
i'm like don't get it's about peace
so it's like it's beautiful having sense
pleasures and enjoying that aspect of
being human
but
not to trick ourselves into that's there
because i rather feel peace
now
after a year of this
and realizing it's not there i guess
mcqueen equanimity yeah
yeah
yeah
interesting so um you know as as we were
just talking that last bit i noticed
that
um if you ask a really abstract question
like what's your favorite sensation
um people will give you a very abstract
answer because you went all the way to
like bliss or peace which like really
encompasses like a lot of sensory
experience
um but if i ask you something that's a
lot more focused and narrow like what's
your favorite food you see how much more
like focused and narrow on just one
aspect of like sensory experience that
was a really interesting um
like
little realization or insight there into
like the whole that you can really go
particle or you can go way more wave
and it's just really cool
okay um
what texture
of
piece and bliss
like do you really love like what's the
texture of it that like oh
[Music]
bliss i just think of the bohemian
rhapsody song because it goes all the
way from
in my perception of it from hell to
heaven so it gives me bliss to
experience my whole hero's journey in
one song and i'm like ah that's blissful
it's like yum
peace
the texture of it how can i describe it
in a song or something or
it's just silence
it's
more like a scene like just
the mundane how can i see it right now
i'm doing laundry or doing the dishes or
even cleaning things that i had never
had to do before and now that i'm being
a no man
and i do those things and as before i
used to do them trying to get somewhere
or being like i need to become someone
in life now i do it from i feel so much
peace and i can have my mind empty while
i do this dishes or i can clean the room
and be like ah like no thoughts and just
being there fully so that's the texture
of like how much peace can you allow not
only meditation but in your normal
day-to-day activities so that's my
favorite texture at the moment
yeah
great answer so
yeah that reminds me a lot of like
sahaja yogi like weaving your absorption
into your daily activities so there's
the that's kind of like the tantric
weaving um approach to like anchoring
heaven on earth
um
and i love that for the peace and then i
also loved when you were talking about
peace just the silence the silence or
like the very
this this-ness um
and
uh and just like what a relief that is
it's so relieving for that it's just
that's a good way i guess another
texture it's like total relief of like
all things avatar and all things
creation
is like that
and then bliss i liked what you said
with bohemian rhapsody because it does
take you on
the whole spectrum the whole roller
coaster itself
and
then that gives you the whole like
spectrum of sensation itself like which
is yeah
cool
for eight minutes epic no need to watch
a movie the whole hero is journeying one
song i'm like
yeah
beautiful
and that's why when we were like
i don't know it was like middle school
or something like on the bus listening
on those like those i those i pod
touches with the wheel and like you'd
split a headphone with like your little
eighth grade friend and you would just
listen to bohemian rhapsody and you
would you wouldn't really understand
like what exactly like why but like now
you're an adult and you're like
that's why
yeah that's it i'm like burly i'm trying
to be in a little bit yeah
yeah
oh beautiful
yeah i do have to go now i'm enjoying
this blood but i see danny looking at me
like we have thanksgiving
perfect exactly and that was such a nice
surprise to see him too
yeah
yeah
yeah i love you guys both um yeah have
fun uh on thanksgiving the rest of the
day
and
um thanks for coming on the show again
nikki such a pleasure
yeah i loved it so fun would love to
come again yeah such a such a cool
variety of topics that were that were
covered great analogies also things that
i feel like are going to be really
useful for all our other selves to watch
and enjoy
um
and also everybody um thank you for
tuning in we love you very much
thank you
thank you for being here
thank you everyone thank you thank you
for tuning in check out the links in the
bio below uh again it's nikki's website
her youtube subscribe to the channel
check out the videos good stuff there
and also her instagram profiles check it
out you can sign up for one-on-ones if
you'd like with her
and
also if you also like the video this
interview itself definitely like the
video it helps algorithm subscribe to
the channel if you haven't yet leave a
comment below with your thoughts on the
video and also share the video with
other people that you feel like it would
profoundly influence positively
that's all folks
love you so much nikki thank you sweetie
bye guys thank you okay i'm gonna i'm
gonna end the stream and then we'll just
we'll stick stay for just
a couple more seconds hold on